Technos by Arc System Works billy and
jimmy had put an end to the Ginn sub
scam technique and we're building so
sets can dojos across the US but one day
on their way to one of the West Coast
dojos they were attacked by a mysterious
group this was the beginning of their
next journey
[Music]
double dragon for
[Music]
the mysterious enemies were called
the Renegades the Renegades answered to
their boss Jake but what were they after
Billy and Jimmy headed to Japan in
search of someone called Okada a name
they picked up from the Renegades
[Music]
the battle was only just beginning
[Music]
the enemies are a familiar group sue
billy and jimmy have defeated again and
again the black warriors
three of the Renegades now control the
black warriors though originally the two
groups were enemies now the group that
pulls the strings these enemies are
based in Japan finally the boss and his
henchmen the bosses subordinates are all
martial arts masters use the power of
socit skin to take them all down
[Music]
in two player dual mode two players
fight each other one-on-one
[Music]
the further you progress in the story
the more playable characters you get for
this mode
[Music]
there is now a new tower mode climb the
tower until you run out of strength
the rules for this mode are simple
defeat all of the enemies on the screen
and proceed to the next floor the higher
up the tower you go the more playable
characters you unlock for all modes use
new characters and take down stronger
enemies do you have what it takes to
defeat the secret boss
[Music]
double dragon for
[Music]
for PlayStation 4 and Steve
you